just two days all nevadans aged 16 and  older will be able to get the covet 19  vaccine  it's the largest group of people to  become eligible for the shot  the southern nevada health district says  vaccination sites are prepared for an  influx of people  and do not anticipate long wait times at  the cashman center  or at the convention center we have  you know 4 500 first dose appointments  2500 second dose appointments set at  each of the big sites  so you know it's you know 7 000  appointments  over six days for two sites we can  handle that  now with the new travel guidelines set  to welcome more visitors to las vegas  health officials are encouraging  everyone to get their shot when they can